hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
ich habe heute ein kleines video über
kräuter wahrscheinlich wird es ein
kleines video sondern eher ein größeres
ihr wisst ja dass ich ganz gerne in der
küche immer mit frischen kräutern koche
und ne zeit lang hatte ich meine kräuter
auch hier im hintergrund aber
mittlerweile habe ich mir für die
terrasse ein hochbeet gekauft und
zusammengebaut und pflanzt die kräuter
eben dort an und ich möchte heute ein
paar kräuter vorstellen die ich gerne
benutzte die ich zu hause habe und
möchte später daneben euch und das
hochbeet zeigen als oftmals ist das so
wenn man in der küche frische kräuter
haben möchte geht man in den supermarkt
und kaufte sich zum beispiel so ein top
mit frischen kräutern hier habe ich
jetzt ein basilikum und hat aber oft das
problem dass dieter nach wenigen tagen
schon kaputt gehen
das liegt einerseits daran dass musste
entweder zu wenig oder zu viel liest
oder dass sie einfach zu wenig licht
bekommen also gerade basilikum ist so
ganz speziell der post im sonnenlicht er
braucht viel feuchtigkeit und vor allem
braucht viel platz und bei den kräuter
töpfen ist es so da gibt ja diesen
mythos dass die supermärkte da was rein
mischen damit die kräuter zu hause
kaputtgehen lassen was ihr immer wieder
nachkaufen muss das stimmt allerdings
nicht
es ist einfach nur so hier sind viel zu
viele sträucher angepflanzt
zum einen deswegen wenn man jetzt hier
nur eins oder zwei pflanzen hätte wird
es ja keiner kaufen für ungefähr 2 euro
weil man sich dann sagt hey für dieses
geld möchte ich natürlich auch was haben
und zum anderen sind es natürlich auch
platzgründen diese basilikum strauch
hier also das sind jetzt ja bestimmt 10
12 pflanzen drin
die brauchen natürlich viel platz das
heißt man muss sie umtopfen und wenn man
das im supermarkt direkt zu kaufen würde
weil es natürlich ein transportproblem
und das ist einfach platzsparender so
der murat hat mir jetzt diesen basilikum
im topf gestern mitgebracht ich habe
jetzt ein paar mal gegossen und werden
später dann einfach umtopfen das heißt
bei so einem top ist es jetzt so denn
müsste auf jeden fall mindestens
vierteln und könnt dann aus diesem einen
topf vier weitere töpfe machen oder ihr
nehmt einfach zum beispiel in großen
blumenkasten gibt da etwas an suchte er
dazu so kräuter erde mit rein
und könnte es da eben reinsetzen so hat
jede pflanze ausreichend platz und kann
einfach für sich wachsen denn wenn sie
jetzt in dem topf geblieben wären ist
jede pflanze um sich kämpfen und kämpft
um die nährstoffe im boden und so können
sie einfach schön wachsen haben alle
platz und jede pflanze bekommt genug
nährstoffe aus der erde
stimmt ihr zu
und ich hab jetzt hier schon ein paar
kräuter gerichtet und zwar habe ich die
von der terrasse geerntet ich zeige euch
jetzt mal samira spielt hier gerade mit
schnittlauch und der schnittlauch ist so
rossi da aus den habe ich einfach direkt
abgeschnitten
man muss nur beim ernten darauf achten
dass man unten so etwa 2 für 1 bis 2 cm
noch dran lässt
und jetzt zeige ich euch mal wie man
diese kräuter natürlich auch haltbar
macht weil ich kann ja nicht so viel
schnittlauch an einem tag verbrauchen
und möchte dann auch zum beispiel im
winter was davon haben wenn er draußen
nicht mehr wächst und beim schnittlauch
ist so den werde ich jetzt einfrieren
und andere kräuter könnt ihr auch
trocknen und so haltbar machen also den
haag ich mir jetzt einfach schön klein
und den schnitt lauffähig jetzt in so
einer kleinen schüssel ein und dann
benutze ich ihnen zum beispiel für
saucen für suppen oder für andere
gerichte für salate auch immer ganz gern
oder ich mag ihn auch einfach aufs
butterbrot oder ins auf frischkäse brot
hier habe ich jetzt petersilie vor mir
liegen die habe ich jetzt auch schon
geerntet dann müsste bei der ernte
darauf aufpassen wenn ihr sie ab
schneidet sie dicht am boden weg zu
schneiden und dann wächst sie da eben
auch immer wieder nach und petersilie
ist auch etwas zum einfrieren als solar
richtet gerne auch einfach klein
schneiden in der schüssel reingeben und
anfrieren und es benutze ich dann bei
bedarf zum beispiel auch für soßen und
suppen für salate besonders in der
türkischen küche wird ganz viel
verwendet aber im prinzip als petersilie
eigentlich immer mit reiben
vor allem viele termin 10 und hilft
gegen mundgeruch beim 1 bei mir als
knoblauch liebhaberinnen muss man das
natürlich auch rechnet
basilikum eignet sich übrigens auch
hervorragend dafür dass man ihn
einfriert aber ihr könnt jetzt auch
solche kräuter nicht nur so separat
aller einfrieren und einzeln ihr könnt
sie auch gerne vermischen
zum beispiel kann hier beim basilikum
und paar blätter nehmen
da fangen da übrigens unten an die zu
zupfen
was immer die unteren und können sie
dann mit verschiedenen anderen kräutern
vermischen
ich fühle mich hier zum beispiel
basilikum mit etwas rosmarin dazu hier
diese nadeln runter und stark gebe ich
noch etwas thymian mit dazu und dann
habt ihr zum beispiel so eine mischung
für eine tomatensoße für eine pizza soße
und könnte es dann immer wieder auftauen
und es mache ich jetzt gleich nicht so
trocken sondern ich gebe da etwas was
man mit reiner habt ihr das wiso einen
kleinen kräuter würfel
und da könnte jetzt diese kleinen
portionen so kleine eiswürfel behälter
reihen geben
da können natürlich auch ganz andere
kräuter mischen mit majoran thymian mit
minze egal wie alles was schmeckt oder
was für eine kräutermischung ihr gerade
volt und dann gießt er das mit etwas
wasser auf damit eben auch zu einem
würfel zusammengeführt und könnte es
dann einfach einfrieren und bei bedarf
eben direkt in die soße mit reingeben
den rosmarin habe ich übrigens nicht
komplett geerntet denn der weg sitzt
noch eine weile auf der terrasse und ich
kann dir dann immer wieder frisch
abzupfen
vor allem sind dann diese nadeln auch
noch schön weich und nicht so hart wenn
sie nämlich mal getrocknet sind also man
kann ja auch trocknen
das sieht man jetzt auch hier dann kann
man sie auch zerkleinern und trocken mit
dazu geben
aber nicht jeder mag halt diese nadel
und jetzt könnt ihr die entweder zum
beispiel mit einem mörser zerkleinern
oder mit einem mixer und sie dann
benutzen und rosmarin ist für mich so
ein gewisses gehört auf jeden fall immer
mit dazu vor allem bei kartoffeln bei
fleischgerichten hat einfach so diesem
frischen geschmack und mag ich ganz
gerne
und genau so ist es jetzt hier auch beim
thymian den habe ich auch nicht komplett
geerntet sondern benutzt ihn dann frisch
von der terrasse aber auch den kammern
trocknen und dann eben auch wie zum
beispiel hier beim rosmarin zu trocken
benutzen und hier vorne habe ich jetzt
auch bereits minze liegen und etwas
oregano und zwar liegen die jetzt schon
seit etwa vier tagen die minze habe ich
nämlich durch getrocknet und zu hab ich
sie diesmal mit einem gummiband
zusammengebunden und so als bündel
trocknen lassen
aber meistens wenn ich genug platz in
der wohnung habe ich sie auch ein
sauberes geschirrtuch bereit die blätter
schön aus und legt noch mal was drüber
also so wie hier dann dann trocknen sie
nämlich schneller durch und wenn die
dann trocken ist kann man sich die
blätter hier unternehmen vom stil den
hatten stiegen wollen wir nicht man
können dazwischen den händen
die mindest blätter einfach so
zerkrümeln und ich benutze immer ganz
gerne minze ich habe das einfach vorher
meiner mama von der türkischen küche
da kommt es immer mit dazu zum essen und
wenn ich dann so zerkleinert habe gebe
ich die trockene minze in meinem gewürz
schildchen und kann es dann eben mit zum
essen mit dazu geben
oder man kann zum beispiel auch die
minze auf früh mit heißem wasser und
etwas pfefferminztee machen
also da gibt es eigentlich ganz viele
möglichkeiten wie man sie einsetzen kann
und genauso ist es beim oregano da habe
ich es auch gemacht hat man auch
geerntet trocknen lassen und jetzt kann
ich hier diese blätter abziehen und
einfach klein machen und später dann
eben getrocknet mit dazu geben
hier könnt ihr übrigens sehen dass hier
schon ein paar blüten gewachsen sind
eigentlich lässt man die nicht wachsen
denn sobald ihr blüten seht müsste sie
abnehmen also direkt beim frischen
strauch noch denn sobald eine blüte
daran wächst möchte sich ja diese
pflanze fortpflanzen das heißt sie
steckt die ganze energie und die ganze
kraft in diese blüte und im restlichen
straub ist einfach nicht mehr so viel
geschmack die vorher deswegen schneidet
ihr solche blüten immer direkt ab damit
sie einfach also damit die gesamte
geschmack und die gesamte kraft im kreis
selber drin bleibt und eben nicht in die
blüte geht und das waren jetzt
eigentlich so meine wichtigsten kräuter
wollte wahrscheinlich wissen wie ich sie
draußen auch angepflanzt habe mein
hochbeet habe ich ja schon seit mai und
meinem bruder hat es so gut gefallen
dass es sich jetzt auch 1 gestellt hat
und wir fahren jetzt einfach mal kurz zu
meinem bruder und bauen zusammen das
bethaus wissen jetzt bei mein bruder und
ich klingle jetzt einfach nur
hallo moralisch dabei und wird dabei ich
bin nicht freiwillig da ich lauf hier
durchaus warum wisse jetzt war mein
bruder im garten dass ich mein bruder
charlie man hätte ihn aber auch albert
der hesse wurde so aussieht glück dass
ich mutter bitte kurz darf danach machen
wenn wir ihn nicht mehr braucht
und hier zu meiner linken steht der
berner trainer habe ich auf mein markt
kennen gelernt mit seiner lieben frau
und zwar habe ich da das hochbeet
gekauft und eigentlich haben wir auch
seine verbundenheit weil ich habe auch
mein hobby zum beruf gemacht und du ja
auch als ein teurer das wieder hochgeht
nur ein hobby und jetzt ist es zum beruf
wird genau und der wiener ist auf der
hersteller von dem hochbeet und ich
würde sagen wir bauen das heißt wie ihr
baut es jetzt kurz auf im prinzip kann
man das auch alleine mache aber die zwei
männer machen gesetzt kurz zusammen da
geht es nämlich noch viel schneller ich
bin froh dass er wieder dabei ist
schwabe der weiß wie das geht da ahmed
ali helfen einfach ein bisschen nach wir
starten jetzt einfach mal
also das hochbeet ist aufgebaut zu hause
hab das natürlich gemacht da war ich
noch nicht hoch schwanger habe ich ja
das jetzt mein bruder mit dem berner
gemacht und mein bruder hat jetzt hier
so ein kiesbeet sag ich mal
und er hatte da so nur anti unkraut
matte drin damit eben da beim kies jetzt
kein unkraut wächst aber timo seitz
wegschneiden denn wenn jetzt da das
hochbeet darauf stellen das ist jetzt
anders als bei mir auf der terrasse wäre
jetzt ehrt kontakt und deswegen muss die
matte hier drunter weg damit einfach das
bild gleich darauf gestellt wird und
dann eben auch von unten aus der erde
zum beispiel auch regenwürmer und so
weiter mit in das hochbeet rein kommen
könne
auf meiner terrasse habe ich ja sowas
nicht weil ich habe da kein erstkontakt
da habe ich ja so eine schale drunter
jetzt kommt das und geht darauf dass
bewegt einfach dass da jetzt keine
wühlmäuse dann ins hochbeet hoch können
romane oder maulwürfe aber trotzdem
könne halt so kleine tiere wie zum
beispiel regenwürmer ins hochbeet rein
was ja auch ganz wichtig ist aber das
erkläre ich euch gleich nochmal
ich helfe mit dass ich ganz leicht
was aufgebaut und ich würde jetzt
einfach mal kurz erzählen wie sie
brauchen überhaupt ein hochbeet also
haben hochbeet zuhause ich koche eben
gern mit frischen kräutern
deswegen ist es bei mir ganz praktisch
auf der terrasse und auf meiner terrasse
ist eigentlich nur ein hochbeet logisch
weil wenn man das in so kleinen balkonen
töpfen jetzt sage ich macht da wächst
eben auch das kraut oder die wachsen die
kräuter nicht so gut wie jetzt in einem
hochbeet die arbeitshöhe ist natürlich
ziemlich optimal weil ich einfach mich
nicht ständig bücken muss auf dem boden
zum beispiel mein bruder hat jetzt ja
auch dass seine kräuter hier auf dem
boden pflanzen können aber da hat man
eben nicht diese arbeitshöhe muss immer
am boden arbeiten und für den rücken ich
selbst auch nicht besonders gut deswegen
eben das hochbeet dann hat nur noch
einen vorteil da kommt jetzt nicht
einfach erde rein also anzuchterde
sondern da kommen jetzt gleich
verschiedene schichten mit rein und ich
muss dann einfach die die sachen die ich
da drin gepflanzt habe also die kräuter
oder die salate zum beispiel muss ich
dann nicht ständig dingen weil einfach
die erde dann arbeitet aber das sage ich
euch dann gleich wenn wir das gleich
machen
und wieso habe ich ein hochbeet aus
aluminium
ganz einfach es gibt ja auch hochbeete
aus holz die sie natürlich in der
anschaffung etwas günstiger aber wenn
man am ende dann mal berechnet und so
zurückblickt kommt man so eigentlich
doch günstiger weg denn aus holz das
erweitert hier auch vor allem weil es im
freien steht hier steht jetzt auch unter
freiem himmel bei mir auf der terrasse
auch holz geht mit der zeit kaputt es
wird nass es fängt an zu schimmeln
ich muss es jedes jahr neu streichen ich
musste streichen nicht du eigentlich der
murat und deswegen haben wir uns halt
dagegen entschieden weil irgendwann in
ein paar jahren ist es natürlich auch
kaputt und das hier ist eigentlich für
die ewigkeit
es kaufe ich einmal und hab es dann halt
wirklich ewig dach stehen also gegen
holz spricht für mich eben dass es
kaputt geht vor allem tätig feuchtigkeit
jetzt gerade hier im garten hat man auch
die feuchtigkeit für unten aus der erde
und das holz eben
man könnte natürlich auch im hochbeet
aus zum beispiel steinen bauen sowie
hier vorne aber die sind halt ziemlich
schwer also transportiert das jetzt
erstmal bei uns in den dritten stock
nach oben und da brauche ich ja ziemlich
viel um auf dieser höhe dann auch zu
kommen deswegen finde ich dass alle
gestellt eigentlich am besten weil es
leicht ist es sieht auch hübsch aus
man kann es immer schön sauber machen
und es ist eben einfach praktisch wir
machen jetzt hat die erste schicht rhein
und die besteht aus grobem holz also
unbehandeltes holz alles rein damit dass
er noch nägel dann deutlich noch nie
deine vortragsreihen das macht nichts
aus und die erste schicht die ist ganz
wichtig und zwar ist die grobe schicht
also die größte schicht von allen und
die bewegt einfach das ist auch später
dieses wasser absichern kann also dass
man keine staunässe hat wir haben zum
beispiel bei uns auf der terrasse daheim
auch noch so kees also steine mit drin
das brauchen wir hier jetzt nett weil
die haben wir den erstkontakt und hier
fließt das wasser sowieso dann unten in
die erde ab
die hölzer haben bei zu sammeln der
stamm hat genau also die schicht ist es
ganz wichtig das ist die grobe schicht
und wir machen jetzt da gleich vier
schichten reinartz 20 zentimeter
ungefähr und was mein bruder in spa grad
macht der verdichtet das ganze damit
eben alles runter geht
das können auch den mut mache
und das also dass sie ganz grobe schicht
die verwesten am langsamsten und wir
machen jetzt eben vier verschiedene rein
und dann verwesen die immer zu einer
anderen zeit und man hat dann eben
diesen effekt dass man sieben jahre lang
das eben nicht düngen muss sozusagen bis
zumindest die experten also bisher haben
wir alles einfach im wald gesammelt vom
boden da kommt jetzt die zweite schicht
das ist die feinere schicht die
laubschicht
und zu dieser feinen schicht kann man
jetzt auch noch karten wiederzugeben
das ist ein alter schwäbischer trick und
zwar richtung auch die lieblingsnahrung
der regenwürmer haben sie uns zumindest
zugeflüstert aber auf jeden fall ist der
karton nichts anderes als zellulose
liste setzt sich ja auch deswegen bevor
das zum altmühl mit dazu gibt's zum
altpapier gibt es einfach mit rein
und jetzt müssen wir das ganze ganz gut
befeuchtet damit sich ein mal eben setzt
und außerdem brauchen ja die lebewesen
auch feuchtigkeit und sauerstoff und
deswegen mache ich das jetzt einmal
schöner
mein bruder hat jetzt hier noch ein
bisschen mutter erde und dafür jetzt
auch noch mal so 20 bis 30 cm 1 das
haben jetzt einfach hier aus dem
nachbarsgarten vom alex hat aus nachbars
garten geklaut und ich war jetzt einfach
kurz bis er das eis gefüllt hat und ich
mache noch ein bisschen kompost
ihr könnt hier an der stelle zum
beispiel auch einfach bisschen kompost
reinschmeißen so wie ich jetzt mein
apfel und dann gehen wir gleich noch mit
komposterde mit drauf also alles was an
biomüll habt könnt ihr alles mit rein
geben
und das ist jetzt der letzte große sack
komposterde samstag übrigens
jetzt einfach noch mal diese befeuchten
der sich jetzt die letzte schicht ist
nur an sucht erde eine kräuter erde das
substrat drinnen ist eine ganz feine
erde damit einfach die kräuter eben
besser wachsen und rein damit
und ich sehe jetzt schauen wie viel da
reinpasst und deswegen ist es auch ganz
gut gedacht vom berner weil dieser
kasten ist nicht quadratisch oder
rechteckig sondern da geht danach unter
nach unten wiesen v
das heißt unten passt weniger rein oben
passt mehr rein und murat freut sich
natürlich als schwabe muss endlich
weniger kaufen weniger tragen
und deswegen ist es ja ganz praktisch
wenn man sich jetzt auch selber baut aus
holz muss man sehr praktisch so
quadratisch machen oder rechteckig und
dann muss man eben noch viel mehr
einführen
aber wir sind ganz froh dass es nur noch
wenig ist
also mein bruder hat sich jetzt hier so
ein paar kräuter ausgesucht und paar
habe ich ihm mitgebracht und zwar aus
den töpfen habe aus dem globus gekauft
im supermarkt und mehr pflanzen ist
jetzt ein wichtig ist dass man jetzt
nicht zuviel einpflanzen das wächst ja
alles noch und man muss mal hand stammt
dreckig aber muss halt auch ein bisschen
erfahrung sammeln was will das jetzt so
ein bisschen was bleibt gerade und ja
auch ich kenne mich da nicht so perfekt
aus aber ich denke wir kriegen das gut
hin
wir haben jetzt hier zum beispiel ein
strauch rosmarin da wissen wir der
wächst ziemlich groß aber man kann denn
ihr später immer noch umsetzen in einen
topf deswegen können wir jetzt hier an
züchten und dann kannst du immer noch
entscheiden wurde ihn hinhaben will
später mal und ich würde sagen mit zeige
sein falls bei einem mal da macht man
sich schon ob ich werde jetzt halt
nochmal angefeuchtet muss man jetzt tief
genug mache ich liebte es total mit der
erde zu spielen
ich glaube dass für die iss für die
seele macht es auch immer ganz gern
dann setzt man hat es hier direkt mit
der erde ein jetzt wieder zugedeckt und
dann haben wir schon im fernen ersten
schnittlauch strauch da drin
die andere direkt daneben und haben
jetzt hier unseren schnittlauch hier
haben wir dann hinten so eine basilikum
reihe hier zwischendrin ein bisschen
petersilie hier so ein bisschen peperoni
paprikasorten da der rosmarin und dann
noch ein bisschen thymian gott was geht
genau mit den jetzt fertig haben alles
schön eingeplant bei uns hat es am
anfang auch so aus also noch ziemlich
leer aber des wechsels alles richtig
schön was ich euch jetzt noch ganz kurz
zeigen wollte ist hier dieser abschluss
hier geht es um schnecken schutz und
zwar können da gerade im garten jetzt
schnecken von außen nicht darüber
klettern also nicht drüber was machen
die die robben so vor sich hin
genau und griechen genau griechen
schlägt also auf jeden fall der
schnecken schutz und hier außen wie so
ein kinderschutz denn die außenkante
hier ist er ziemlich spitz deswegen gibt
es diese kappe drauf wie kann man sich
daran kleben mit doppelseitigen
klebeband und dann kann man sich da auch
nicht verletzen und das ist jetzt ein
kräuterbeet und ich zeige euch jetzt wie
mein kräuter wird zu hause auf der
terrasse mittlerweile aussieht
ich will noch sitzen mal sein bruder
zeigen weil den seht ihr das allerletzte
mal jetzt zwischen w ok so sieht es
kräuter hoch wie jetzt bei mir aus ich
habe natürlich gestern alle kräuter
schon mal geerntet aber vor ein paar
tagen sah das kräuterbeet nämlich noch
so aus da war es noch ganz dicht
bewachsen und vor allem voller kräuter
also ich möchte jetzt hier ganz kurz
zeigen was ich hier drin habt und zwar
habe ich hier salbei da hatte ich oft
nicht zwei sträucher eingesetzt und
salbei ist also eine pflanze die
vermehrt sich ziemlich schnell wird sehr
groß deswegen würde ich die nicht mehr
in ein hochbeet setzen außer möchten
hochbeet nur mit salbei
hier habe ich noch rosmarin den werde
ich auch umsetzen müssen weil der
einfach viel mehr platz braucht vor
allem die wurzel unten
hier hatte ich etwas oregano der ging so
ein bisschen unter aber es war auf jeden
fall genug
hier habe ich meinen schnittlauch den
habe ich es gestern auch komplett
geerntet und der kommt dann auch immer
wieder mal habe ich petersilie und bei
petersilie macht man so die ernte mal
ganz dicht am boden als ich habe ich
also man nimmt dann einfach den stecker
ganz unten und kannst du einfach weg
reißen und dann kommt er auch immer
wieder nach
und hier diese ganz große fläche war
voll mit minze obwohl ich nur hier hier
und hier ich hatte wirklich nur hier und
hier minster drin aber die hat sich halt
komplett nach hinten auch vermehrt und
hat hier auch den basilikum getötet als
decking total unter und nächstes jahr
werde ich auf jeden fall so machen dass
ich mir hier so ein trainer einsätze
also darauf bisschen weiter runter geht
bis zu den wurzeln
dann mache ich die hälfte voll mit minze
und hier mache ich schon ein bisschen
petersilie schnittlauch und oregano und
bei uns fast so wir haben das
kräuterbeet beim einsetzen nicht so arg
verdichtet das sieht man jetzt auch hier
die erde ist auch ziemlich weit nach
unten gesagt oh guck mal da stand ein
kleiner freund marcel ziehen wir die
insekten heran
und deswegen werden wir nächstes jahr
wenn wir da wieder raus rein pflanzen
auf jeden fall wieder mehr erde mit rein
geben und beim verdichten war es also
wir haben eine gießkanne und kein
gartenschlauch deswegen wollte murat
letzte oft laufen hat das was ein fehler
und ich bin ganz froh dass wir das
hochbeet aus alu haben denn das hat ja
unten diese auffangschale also das haben
wir bei uns auf der terrasse natürlich
mit dabei ansonsten wird er immer alles
auf die steine gehen und hier könnte mal
gucken sie hatten wir so ein gefäß aus
stein und es hat und neben auch löcher
unterstützen fleck drauf also der fleck
geht auf jeden fall wieder weg muss es
halt nur sauber machen
das hat nämlich er verursacht aber wenn
man sich jetzt überlegt ich hätte jetzt
ein hochbeet aus holz hier drauf und
zwar so vermutet hätte ich jetzt hier
einfach flecken auf der terrasse die
einfach nicht mehr weggehen würden
deswegen ist das hier mit dieser schale
echte ideale lösung auf jeden fall war
die nachfrage nach diesem kräuter
hochbeet so groß dass ich jetzt mit dem
hinter gesprochen habe und ihr könnt das
jetzt auch gerne bei uns im shop
erwerben
ihr müsst ihr einfach eben auf den shop
gehen auf seinen job wieder gibt es
daneben noch mal und ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat ich hoffe ihr
konntet einige informationen und
mitnehmen und ich konnte euch das so ein
bisschen erklären falls ihr doch mal
fragen habt stellt sie einfach unten in
den kommentaren
ich werde euch dann einfach beantworten
und ja ich geht's wieder nach drinnen
murat muss später wieder gießen heute
abend und ich lasse es mir gut gehen
bis zum nächsten mal